I'm Peru and I'm Diego and we are here
to talk about computational X X cap box
we are exciting to share with you how we
can engage our kids into problem-solving
in a modern world and the Wolfram
language is the most powerful tool
available for the kids to engage in
computational thinking we hope you
really enjoy the talk so welcome
everybody I'm Pedro and my name is Diego
and we're very happy to have you two
here today so we are talking about
computational xscape Docs but actually
are going to talk about an education
project an education idea based on games
it could be excape box it could be a
Trivial Pursuit
whatever so the abstract is a little bit
based on and the xscape concept in the
sense that it is a game that is played
typical with multiple persons and the
purpose is to crack puzzle to get into
the box or sometimes in it in sanik
skype room to get outside of the room
but well the purpose here is just to try
to use a computational thinking to solve
a puzzle yes so so it's projects to
explore computational thinking through
connected devices for people that don't
actually have problems to solve yes and
this is an important concept is that
many times we ask young kids to figure
out a solution to a problem and many
times they don't even understand the
purpose of solving that problem because
well they have never encountered that
needs before yes and so we thought well
let's try to figure out how to motivate
kids to try to use compressional
thinking to solve problems and well
connected devices is always a good
motivation strategy because it's
something that we can touch that we can
experience yes well they haven't solved
life problems before yes and typically
solving other problems it's not the most
motivating task
yes and when we try to get them to
choose projects for their computational
thinking they tend to be a little bit
too complex like I don't know Mars rover
car or fighting robot or something like
that and so so the idea is telling the
subject around
it's basically also getting them to
start playing with the hammers right so
you need to learn how to use a hammer so
you don't get your finger messed up so
you know okay go and search some nails
that you can use with this hammer so
we're gonna use some of the sensors or
different elements around there and
we're gonna ask them to find a problem
to solve within different domains well
in what X on what domain of knowledge
that you are over there can you apply
this concept so you know at the
beginning when you start thinking okay
we're going to talk about computational
thinking it's very abstract so we need
to bring it to something for the kids
that it's something that you can touch
right so let's restrict the domain to
things that people can touch and also
things that people can interact and
there it's simple to use and kids love
games so why not have them build games
yes so what we have on top of the table
there are a few interfaces let's say
human machine interfaces similar to the
one that you are seeing here on the
picture the frames were actually freely
printed and then well few things glued
on top of it the idea was to build a box
and so you can actually mount a few of
these together and get a hole that's SOI
soccer ball format yes we just kept them
like this because it's easier to
transport our plane and stuff like that
and and we're going to play with those
yes so the collaboration is OK we need
to also train the kids that is cool you
know you're by yourself you're graded
based on what you do individually the
important things is also to get the kids
to start working as teams so
we can provide each kid with a challenge
to build a Pentagon the Pentagon will be
self-contained it will have each each
team can work on different concepts and
then all of them come together to
finalize the solution or a prototype and
each group will think about they're
gonna have a specific interface and
we're going to go through that and I'm
gonna have to start thinking or the
things they see at school
or whatever they like on TV is what
areas of domains can I solve with this
sensor or program so advantages of
connected devices let's process here
some initialization cells so they are
very cheap yes they allow to learning
the concept of data acquisition that's
extremely important for the real world
and the world is messy and so it brings
a kind of reality to to the table
because well typical school exercises
well science is exact and that's not
real life yes for instance here we have
an acceleration being measured well of
course we are measuring the
gravitational acceleration and obvious
we don't have 9.8 because well the
instrument is not calibrated and we have
values that vary around and of course
because there's some movement sound and
things like that where is that where is
the airplane so this is an Anton Antonov
here airplane and we have Anton here
that is going to help us on the
demonstration and as you can see well
while he's playing with with the
airplane we we are getting different
values yes we also have a scale so this
could be objects that the kids would
have built if Anton can lift up the
airplane you can see that there's an
airplane with with a power bank and he's
he's trying to break it but that that's
fine
you see it's set for kids so kids so it
will be fine
so let's try to do a small exercise with
with
light yes that is we talked about
multiple domains to be discussed with
one single interface and then multiple
interfaces put together in kind of a
game a quiz yes but let's see what we
could for instance invent to be solved
with with the light probe so we have
luminance sensor that mountain is
searching for and and it's so it's
constantly showing that the value here
and so for instance the question is the
current light correct for your study yes
so Anton is the current light correct
for your study do you have enough light
to read the book and the room Anton what
you think what you think so you we have
265
265 looks is it correct or not yes or no
is it
EU approved yes so can you click again
on s ok so sir so and it should change
so it's something wrong with that with
the database connection but this is a
lot of technology going around because
it's a it's saying that last answer was
well a little bit too long ago for it to
be the real answer but let's just go
forward so let's check if light
conditions are good for study well it
they are not yes and so we are kind of
on life sciences this kind of topics if
we go to physics can for instance we
double the current light so if we pick a
phone or or or whom can you make the
light double that we get the looks and
so this gives a sensation of what is a
real intensity of light what is doubling
the intensity of light he's trying he's
trying to to do the other way around and
so we did got a ratio of well
there you go he doubled it yes well he
he multiplied a little bit that the
amount of flight yes and and if we if we
try to get well we are at 6,000 now yes
so that will be a little bit harmful to
our eyes and so on the single interface
we are exploring multiple concepts
concepts of physics concepts of
literature can we actually use a
luminance sensor to explore literature
well that's the real exercise of this
that is how can we have kids thinking on
problems based on when interface instead
of thinking of a problem and finding the
solution let's try to find a problem
that fits with main interface because
they will come up with their own type of
problems yes which is probably not what
we have here yes so on literature when
mr. Ratchett was murder was it lighter
or darker than your current set so who
is this guy mr. Ratchett well we know
that it is a fictional character okay
where did he appear yes well he appeared
on Murder on the Orient Express yes and
well for people of our age we know when
he was murdered during the day or the
night now we have the 2017 movies though
a lot of younger generation also know
but let's try to find the answer was mr.
Ratchett murdered during night or day
time yes and so a little bit of
competition thinking to find the answer
yes and so what we are doing is that we
are searching on Wikipedia data for the
film because it's a little bit more
explicit than the original story on
Wikipedia information and we ask for the
question yes
with that find textual answer and well
we actually have a few answers here but
we can actually figure out very quickly
that that night well who hears strange
noises coming from watch's compartment
and later sees
one in the red okay and we have here
somewhere that he was murdered yes the
night convo like a second weekend it's
somewhere there that he was murdered
okay after next morning the news release
or murdered endured during the night yes
that's it yes and so we actually used
competition of thinking to find very
quickly an answer
now it could imagine that this could be
a quiz that would be played in parallel
with multiple teams and so the ones that
came up with the compilation of thinking
strategy that would give the answer the
fastest would win a prize
something like that yes now I'm just
going to clean up my code here and
remove the scheduled tasks that we had
running so we talked about the
interfaces this is actually what using
on top of of the table so we build all
kinds of interfaces and we just divide
and conquer as we were saying that we
were going to ask the kids to do so
Pedro in Portugal with his kids built a
whole series of interfaces with
joysticks yes and no buttons light
sensors and a weight and over here with
it at home with the rotary and resistors
and push buttons so what we're going to
do is going to try the different
problems from simple to complicated so
Anton when my time is up in this world
in which direction will I go so you have
to decide if I'm going up or down okay
yeah yeah well depends on how you answer
okay so Anton said that I'm going to
heaven which I don't believe it but
that's the case Thank You Anton for
trusting me now
Amy would love this Amy Friedman is okay
so we were going to look now into
literature
okay and how do we use the weight system
the scale to answer a literature
question so well we are going to
challenge the whole room to based on a
phrase from a Shakespeare play
what is that we need to do with this
scale so what we're doing is okay we're
gonna ask Mathematica about what was
[ __ ] asking the judge for payment
that he wanted his money so based on
search going through the web search and
using the find textual answer we get an
answer he wanted a pound of flesh
all right so I'm torn we need a pound of
flesh okay we are not getting feedback
from the database but yes so let's move
on yes it's because you need four points
15 thank you and so to have an idea of
what that would be we can ask what from
alpha well it would be a little bit less
than a liver my believer something like
that so hmm
it was giving a little bit too much that
thing yes and now we're going to go to
something more complex
these sensors has multiple feedback
loops and what we're going to ask Anton
after he finishes with the weight is if
he can fly the Anton airplane for us and
again and again we are not getting a
feedback on that one from the database
but that's why it's just at the battery
whereas we have power banks here that
are easy to carry on the airplanes
there's no questions on what is a power
bank which we put a couple of batteries
big batteries they will complain and and
the problem of of a power bi
is that if he doesn't recognize
consumption enough it just comes out
these instruments are so light in terms
of consumption that they can live for a
few days on these power banks that well
from the beginning of the presentation
up to now it's already disconnected
itself but Anton has just connected
again to the power bank it is most
likely running the script to connect to
the database and we should see some
interaction of that spaceship while
heading to the moon in between we are
going to ask where is the direction to
the moon so that Anton knows how to
point it it's not getting feedback when
we are sorry for that if I have yes
so the exes and before going to the exes
well would like to thank Anton for his
participation and I think the Adam
applause thank you he is the proof I
think that he is the proof that going
with this kind of interactions can
actually enthusiasm kids to play around
with the language and the game going
forward well so the main purpose is
actually to turn the problem around that
is not to ask them directly to solve a
problem but to ask what type of problems
could be solved with a given interface
some interfaces are quite difficult to
come up with examples like I don't know
with the temperature can we really solve
a geometry problem
well eventually I have no idea I haven't
thought of it yes but we can think of
the typical axis so math and physics
like scale light accelerometer distances
geography and history so the airplane
versus moon arts and literature where a
lot of things can be done on that and
Counting in finance well why not yes and
and and all these can actually bring a
lot of interest is for let's say
all kinds of of areas yes that is well
with the space station I can actually
sort with the airplane I can actually
use it as a joystick in the world to
point where where a given moment well
for instance the Eiffel Tower is because
it has it is a referenced joystick
pointer to the wall yes and so I can use
it to point where's this base station or
where it's Brad Pitt or where did George
Washington live yes and so we go can go
through multiple disciplines with just
one single instrument yes so also we can
use as we said potentiometers and ask
questions that go from trivia like how
many spouses the Elizabeth Taylor have
and let's see if we can move so we we
are going to put a film here that so
yeah do a film scene and we're gonna
have Anton answer the question so what
is the length of the Nile in kilometers
no you turn around like this so is it
six thousand just presently but press
the button when you think it's right
what's wrong definitely wrong so we can
see that he needs to tell his geography
no it's binary search here so basically
by turning around the resistor you
change the number and you have to select
the right number if you press it you
will say that you're right and we will
go for the next question
and these problems can be auto-generated
through the Wolfram language and the
vote from environment in the sense that
these questions could be almost infinite
yeah sorry if even and actually the
questions were built based on the
Wolfram language and put in a database
so what this is doing is through an API
function in the cloud getting the next
question so well the Wolfram language
has we're saying it's really the best
language to do this kind of interaction
because it knows all kinds of concepts
it can interact very easily with with
devices and and we can do various
educated things with it we just saw the
film attacking with a phone disconnected
phone and we could actually use that
film to capture images us to serve as an
interface now Damien is going to try to
identify a 10-gram image so this is what
he built yes and it says it's a cat so I
don't know Daniel
it was it was it a cat that you wanted
to draw Oh Cameron so sorry the
classifier is not good enough but he's
actually pointing with the phone - well
- whatever he is drawn to it again with
a 10-gram and and and it's very easily
to grab the image from the phone it's
still a cat and with 100% certainty
now this classifier was built sir - to
excuse him this classifier was built
let's say last night with a couple of
images and I can laughs cut more than
YouTube so yes it really it really loves
cats yes right so the infrastructure
what's behind the scenes so we took two
different approaches I work with the
warframe platform and Pedro worked on
with a using an SQL server so basically
what we did and there's another light
there and we're gonna have a Anton save
actually the light is changing or not
what i'm doing here is i'm putting a
progress report which you have to save
this goes from no lights to some colors
so we actually have a pentagon so the
red guns can be used both to serve as
inputs and as outputs yes and actually
to give the transept of a game and if
you want to point it there to give a
concept of a gamer we can actually use
it to report the advancement of of the
let's say after off the cool weather guy
more of the Trivial Pursuit game and the
and advancement through the answers that
people get are actually feedback with
some kind of interface yes and we're
gonna show for example now now they have
all the lights on we're gonna turn it
off using database yes let's use a
filming stance it makes sorry it makes
more sense to use a film to show the
thing film now it's got three lights yes
and so if we go to four lines because
the person got one more correct now this
is very heavy because it's well well
when we started doing this I will know
it was free credits through the API now
it's it will consuming credits but
that's okay it's fun so now we're gonna
have a four yes it refreshes from time
to time like every ten seconds long
there we go and so we actually have a
feedback that one more answer was
correct so why the shape well it's just
a matter a of aggregating multiple
projects so that there's a sense a sense
of collaborative work there actually
doesn't need to be any shape yes it
cannot just be a bunch of interfaces but
outside that is the first step for the
kids to understand what they are doing
and once they have gone through that
step well they can think of many other
interfaces that don't need necessary to
be linked on top of a table or they can
be let's say outside and and more
interesting things yes now the shape
it's like this it was completely 3d
printed and glued together
we tried to do it in Mathematica it's
still a little bit too hard because
boolean operations well sometimes they
work sometimes they're still not there
yes so this would be an example to build
the interface with the difference
between these piece and that piece and
we didn't got there
ten wheeled you use the cut drawing okay
so final thoughts we think that it's a
great exercise for kids in middle and
high school to show that collab by
collaborating between the teams you
divide and conquer problem and you get
to a nice project and a solution that
everybody can have fun it allows for
computational multi domain looking for
problems to solve with the hammers that
we have it's a game so they can actually
build their own let's say quizzes drivel
/ sweet games and cool weather games
something like that yes and it's a step
stone for more complex interactions yes
both interactions more on the software
side and us on this hardware side so it
starts simple it starts with just a
simple push button and it go can go very
far in terms of complexity and so well
coming next
I don't know life cutting competition
with interactive devices something like
that well Westen's please send through
the path of all thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]